série agathe ma chérie je sais qu'ils
ont été très durs avec toi je te voilà
je te vois pas bien et moi je dis tout
en direct
je voulais te dire que on sera toujours
avec toi et que je trouve qu'il fait un
travail formidable quand même eu hier et
que tu avais donner ton avis je trouve
franchement que mathieu de l'ong
origines vous avez été très très dur et
je vous le dis oui franchement surtout
mathieu et c'est pas franchement c'est
pas sympa pour agathe parce qu'elle
donne son avis et je trouve que quand
vous vous avez fait des erreurs
agathe a toujours été là pour vous pour
vous aider et je pense que ça n'a pas
été le cas ni de gym n'est de matinée
des personnes allongées pas d'amis ici
si tu en as tu as par toi et maxime
évidemment mais quand ce soit géraldine
valérie enfin c'est un de mes amis mais
si mais si chanteuse annie elle te dis
ce que je vois pas dire c est déjà belle
n'as pas ton âge mais c'est mon ami tu
as des amis ici et jean michel est ton
ami benjamin avec ton ami dit plus que
vous l'aimez pas ce que c'est et puis on
a eu déjà eu du courage de te dire que
voilà qu'elle et moi je suis là avec des
gens que j'aime je suis dur avec ma
fille tous les jours quand elle est sur
les réseaux sociaux
oui mais je pense que je pense que
l'amour passe par la vérité par la
sincérité et par là et justement ou
sinon je suis langue de bois et on dit
rien journée derrière chantre de l'eau
dit que tu vas bien ça attendez pas à
bagdad n'étaient pas si mauvaises
odessa c'est vrai que donner son avis
elle se remettait en question la manette
super fois qu'il faut pas envoyer bon
samedi quitter le plateau et laisser ma
place à bernard montiel s'il vous plaît
ça m'arrange pas bernard montiel
mais bien sûr allez-y et on vous
retrouvera demain merci mon agathe qui
sera avec nous
et ce n'est pas tout à fait agathe soir
maintenant je comprends pas ce que vous
lui en a mis plein la gueule franchement
et vous avez été très dure avec l ajout
la mieux juste de percer l'abcès et
après du coup on est bien plutôt de
garder ça pour soi et égaux conçoit que
dans les coulisses la mois s'est fait
brasser niçois la direccte unis mais
voilà il est bon c'est normal que la
pauvre la leçon avait pris un petit peu
qu'elle soit un petit peu voilà
chafouine 1 c'est normal que je
t'enfonce moshiri pas grand chose
[Applaudissements]